[Music]
hey everybody its charlie no surprise
HBO just dropped a whole bunch of new
Game of Thrones material they did a new
promo for the Iron Throne that's a very
big callback to the promos that they did
for season 1 like who will wind up in
the Iron Throne so they're a couple big
Easter eggs in this and Easter eggs and
some of the costumes some of the new
costumes that the characters are wearing
so we'll break it down there's a new
brand of the game of Thrones book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video so first big thing here the
fact that they're doing a who will wind
up on the Iron Throne very ambiguous
look at the main cast in some of the
secondary characters people like where's
Gendry couldn't he also possibly wind up
on the Iron Throne because he does have
a claim if he gets legitimized yes it's
totally true there are potential
candidates but thematically what they're
going with here is they just want to
show the main cast in some of the bigger
secondary characters like Brienne
technically isn't main cast but she is
one of the bigger characters sir Jorah
same thing the way they delineate
between the main cast and the rest of
the characters is a little bit different
there's only a couple of core characters
but there are many main cast members so
that's just a technicality but the
really big Easter Egg in here for Game
of Thrones season 1 is the original
teaser trailer the HBO released way back
in January 2011 it was basically the
same thing a bunch of different main
characters sitting on the Iron Throne
because all of HBO's marketing was
centered on the battle for the Iron
Throne the first several seasons they
even named the series Game of Thrones
after the first book technically the
series is called A Song of Ice and Fire
so obviously there's a huge misdirect in
this but if you haven't seen it in a
long time this is that actual first
teaser trailer
winter is coming this one will be long
and the dark things will come so I saw I
know they did it in my bones I know it I
don't want to be cool I want to come
home
my brother has a sword die at my mind my
table my name
we have my party
distrusting me was the wisest thing
you've done everyone who isn't us is an
enemy you kill me your brother's a dead
man
how nostalgic is a tree watching that
season one promo then looking at all
these season eight iron throne promos
and thinking about how much the
characters have changed how much the
power base has changed in the focus of
the show but the whole thing here you
probably realized is all this season
eight for the throne marketing it took
the hashtag they've been using on all
their stuff for the throne even on all
the old clips that they've been posting
is that it's a giant misdirect they
spent the first several seasons of the
show but the characters just focused on
that was all about battling for the Iron
Throne all about rebellion who's gonna
wind up ruling Westeros then around the
end of season 5 the hardhome episode we
finally started to see the show doubling
down on the mythology plot the Song of
Ice and Fire of it all with a major
battle appearance from the night King in
the White Walkers first actual
appearance of the night King on the show
was season 4 episode 4 in that
post-credit scene where you got to see
how the night king made new White
Walkers using Craster's sons like oh
that's where they came from that's who
all these people are fighting this
season so like during season 7 episode 6
when you see them all walking around the
Battle of the lake those are all
Craster's sons but the hardhome episode
was really where the show started to
bifurcate its focus there were still a
lot of characters battling for the Iron
Throne it was still the main focus of
the show in the main focus of the
marketing but they now also started to
focus on the secondary plot of the war
for the dawn the Song of Ice and Fire of
it all which is really what the series
is about by the time you got through
season 6 up to now the balance of those
two storylines has shifted in the focus
now is more about the war for the dawn
defeating the White Walkers with only a
few characters genuinely still caring
about what happens to the Iron Throne
you have people like Cersei you have
some smaller characters probably like
the Lords of the north and the other
Nobles that would care what happens to
the Iron Throne but largely most of the
main characters the main cast only care
about defeating the White Walkers so the
big misdirect was spelled out all in
Daenerys his vision at the end of season
2 in the house of the undying the
reality of the situation this isn't a
story about the battle for the Iron
Throne this is a story about everyone
coming together in putting their
differences aside so that they could
survive winter so to speak
defeat the knight King in his army in
the real wheel that Daenerys keeps
talking about break
I'm going to break the wheel isn't
actually going to be some
socio-political thing about helping
peasants although that's a little bit of
it the real wheel is the Song of Ice and
Fire the cyclical nature of their battle
against the night king and the forces of
the White Walkers there are cyclical
seasons on planet toast the planet where
Game of Thrones takes place the cycle
has been that one group wars with the
children of the forest or an aboriginal
group they engage measures of last
resort using their blackest darkest
magics to raise White Walkers and turn
the local population against themselves
use their great numbers against them
that begets a cycle where in a group
comes together an azure 'hi figure rises
they defeat them back and in the case of
the last long night literally build a
wall to keep them out but they don't
completely deal with the problem so that
cycle repeats and things come back again
they're threatened with a second long
night you have a second Azure 'hi figure
rise up in the form of Jon Snow or
dinners however you want to think about
it if you want to get really technical
about it I would say that Jon Snow is
being positioned as that one figure
although Daenerys and Jon Snow are a
Song of Ice and Fire but Jon Snow
himself is a song of ice and fire
because of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
Stark so it just fits a little bit
better if you focus on Jon Snow but as
Daenerys says they're trying to break
the wheel so the real wheel is is trying
to break the night king end the threat
of the White Walkers forever so that the
cycle is broken and the wheel does not
continue to turn that's why it's so
funny seeing these four the throne iron
throne promos because there probably
won't even be an Iron Throne at the end
of the series and even if it does exist
in some form none of the surviving
characters would probably even care
about it they just care about rebuilding
the realm because the giant chunk of it
is probably gonna get destroyed during
this season so when you see more of
these Iron Throne promos and there
probably will be a lot more between now
and the premiere just remember in the
back of your mind that this really isn't
about the Iron Throne there's just a
complete misdirect on HBO's part but
like I said there are a couple of new
costumes that we see the characters
wearing couple Easter eggs and that I
mentioned Santa's new suit of armor the
sophie Turner mentioned in my last video
so she did this interview where she said
that Sansa was gonna get a new layer of
leather armor in the vein of something
that you'd see Cersei wearing a way more
hardcore intricate version of a dress
with a lot of extra protection laid in
but it's not like she's going to be
rushing the bad
filled with the other people at
Winterfell when the night king shows up
this is probably that outfit that sophie
Turner was referring to it does look way
cooler than goth sonses outfit during
season 7 more elaborate more intricate
in the same way that Circe's costumes
have evolved in the last few seasons
when she's risen to power
so Sansa is now a very powerful figure
in the north the ways dopey Turner
explained it is that the northern Lords
respect her more because she was able to
out Littlefinger's treachery and he'd
been holding some of them under his
thumb especially Yan Royce and the other
Lords of the Vale they hated
Littlefinger more than anything so
they're probably some us once's biggest
champions now as for sonses chances it's
sitting in the Iron Throne the only way
I think she actually sits on that throne
is if she's in King's Landing with Jon
Snow and she spent so much of her
childhood focused on becoming Queen that
she just curious what it actually feels
like to sit on it and she just has a
brief flashback to all those terrible
moments with Joffrey then gets up and
that's the last time she ever sits on it
we also get a new look at Circe's
upgraded costume it's just a more
hardcore looking version of her season 7
costume with the metal shoulder pads
that are so big that look like they're
mini pauldrons the weird thing about her
promo is that she's not wearing her
crown in the picture but that might just
be because they want to have the same
air of ambiguity about the season 8
finale like who's gonna be left alive
who'll be left in power at the end of
all this Cersei is definitely on my
death predictions list I've already done
a number of videos about theories how
that could go down so I'll post links
for that at the end of this no new
costumes for Tyrion or for Jaime I don't
think that either one of them would ever
wind up on the Iron Throne I definitely
think that Jamie's gonna die during
season eight arya has her same costume
she's got needle front-and-center
she still has the Valyrian dagger even
though just the way she's posed here you
can't quite see it on her hip brand is
still in the same outfit he was wearing
during season 7 no change for Brienne
for Davos Theon is wearing a slightly
more elaborate Ironborn suit of armor
and he's got a shiny new sword not a
Valyrian sword mind you but this will
just remind you of how far his character
has come since he was wearing the
similar suit of armor during season two
when he sacked Winterfell
zero honor point for Theon now he's
trying to reclaim some of that honor by
saving Yara and killing Euron and
because it'd be a much bigger payoff for
his arc I do hope that he's the one that
gets to land the killing blow on your on
your on still wearing the same outfit he
had
during season seven obviously I don't
think these gonna wind up on the Iron
Throne but I am expecting some awkward
scenes between him and Cersei because
remember what he wants in the fact that
Cersei will use him for whatever she can
she doesn't care about your on at all so
we'll talk a little bit more about their
collective story arc when we get some
actual footage during the next trailer
grey worm in the same unsullied armor
he's always had sir Jorah also in the
same armor that he got during season
seven with his regular castle-forged
steel sword because remember he let Jon
Snow keep Longclaw Melisandre looks like
she's just wearing a shinier version of
the same dress that she had during
season seven Masson dies same outfit
Samwell also wearing the same outfit we
saw him the season 7 finale Varys in the
Hound both wearing same outfits and then
the night king obviously has not changed
his armor for a very very long time
probably not since he became the night
king but I do like the visual metaphor
presented by this image like the idea
that the night king would win everyone
dies and he winds up sitting on the Iron
Throne controlling the realm now it
would be funny to actually see him sit
on the Iron Throne but keep in mind that
he does have an intelligence and a
knowledge that rivals that of the
three-eyed Raven but he doesn't give a
crap about any of the socio-political
Game of Thrones of it all he doesn't
care about the Iron Throne he doesn't
care about King's Landing he only cares
about adding more fodder to the army of
the Dead and turning everything into the
lands of always winter HBO has been
ramping up its promos week to week so I
do expect the trailer to drop in the
next couple of weeks but they might wait
till early March so if I get any updates
about that I will totally post a video
leave all your requests in the comments
below there's any bonus topics that you
guys want me to cover or any big
questions that you have congratulations
to the winner from my last big video
Julia Ferdinand please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for my
new Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
teaser video and click here for my
playlist of all my Game of Thrones
season 8 previews and other promos and
trailers thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you
guys tonight
you